[Musique]
il aurait pu être chef d'entreprise
avocats aux médecins la vie se chargera
de transformer cet itinéraire banale
bien trop commun pour faire d'un gamin
de clamecy l'un des plus grands marins
du monde
pourtant rien ne prédisposait à la cola
à devenir une star de la voile un
aventurier des océans
son premier contact avec l'eau se fait
ici sur les bords de l'yonne au pied de
l'immense demeure familiale
à 17 ans il décide de créer le canoë
kayak club sur un coup de tête
il négocie avec la mairie débloque une
subvention obtient en gare et mobilise
quelques copains sur son projet ce n'est
pas qu'une lubie déjà alain colas forge
ses qualités de meneur d'hommes
d'organisateur il développe aussi un
goût très marqué pour la compétition
ses proches s'en souviennent encore
c'était la locomotive c'est lui qui nous
tiraient qui a forcé tous toute une
bande de gamins qui ne serait pas trop
quoi faire
en fait nous a amené à la compétition et
au canoë kayak de compétition jusqu'au
jusqu'au plus haut niveau
au niveau des championnats à clamecy
l'enfance d'alain colas est heureuse ou
athées souriante
quand il n'est pas à l'école ou à
s'entraîner sur nos ils aiment se
retrouver dans l'entreprise familiale
son père roger colas a créé de ses mains
une faïencerie renommée alain sear ont
souvent ils découvrent la rigueur
apprend l'amour du bel ouvrage
la passion d'un travail minutieux coup
chaque geste correspond à l'enseignement
d'une longue tradition
la maison du clan cola immense massive
elle surplombe la ville
dehors dans le froid la brume bannissent
souvent l'yonne de dans le coeur sont au
chaud la vie s'écoule tranquille j'ai
encouragé oui mais surtout sa mère la
femme avait toujours rêvé c'est là était
garçon détendre dans la marine
c'est un curieux 1 c'est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui elle n'avait pas peur comme
une mère peut avoir peur qu'on s'en sont
tout ça est parti c'est certain
maintenant ils avaient la taille lycée
du grand père qui était un explorateur
du grand-père explorateurs alain colas
tient le goût des armes de l' aventure
mais par dessus tout celui des voyages
dans sa chambre sous les combles
il mijote son premier coup de poker il
répond à une annonce qui demande à
maître de conférences pour l'université
de sydney en australie
il n'a pas les diplômes correspondants
et reçoit une réponse négative
pas découragé il s'envole pour sydney
demandent une entrevue et obtient le
poste convoité aucune eau à 22 ans cola
professant toge et prend goût aux
régates ici la voile est un sport
national
[Musique]
j'ai pu connaître et à raison d'une par
semaine les conditions les gens sont si
accrocheur sans arrêt alors il ya un
niveau technique
et puis
qu'il appartient cas c'était c'est
encore acide mais qu alain colas
rencontre eric tabarly il lâche tout
pour le suivre sur paint big 3 à bord
l'équipage s'amuse des manière insolite
de ce jeune homme fringant
nous on n'était ni très ouverts ni trash
à l'enfance et du bateau on aimait bien
ce métier on fait le reste du monde nous
intéressait pas donc quelqu'un qui soit
extérieures à notre clan anneaux à nos
rêves en fait s'intéresse à nous donner
un peu c'était un peu perturbant mais
pas gênant mais perturbant c'était
différent c'était c'était un peu un
parisien pour nous mais au sens
quelqu'un qui quiconque connaît pas
c'est qui qui vit pas avec nous qui avec
lesquels on peut pas voir le soulignait
neil point de référence du point de
référence situer au niveau des bateaux
essentiellement uniquement et des
courses et de de ce milieu dans lequel
on vivait pour faire que ça pour acquis
complètement immergé dans le milieu
maritime
colas est fasciné par tabarly il tombe
amoureux fou de pen duick iv le rachète
à la première occasion très vite il sera
convaincu du potentiel énorme de ce
bateau le plus vite possible à la voile
un bonhomme tout seul à bord
et puis à battre les grands prix va vite
c'est valable pour toutes les formules
de bonheur en plus de cela les très
puissants il est très homogène et très
rigide
à la cola est à tahiti quand il décide
de participer à la transat anglaise en
solitaire de 1972 avec theora sa
compagne il doit d'abord ramener le
bateau jusqu'en bretagne trois mois de
mer pour se mettre paint big 4 en main
mesurer la difficulté de la navigation
en solitaire à prendre la manoeuvre
d'une bête de course compliquée
capricieuse et quand ils pointent ses
étraves à la trinité l'un des rares
témoins de son arrivée se souvient
j'étais par digoin le sol journalistes
présents et de là j'ai enchaîné d'abord
j'ai découvert que cole avait
considérablement vie dans sa tête que
deuxièmement il était devenu un sacré
marin que tabarly était décidément un
bon prof
et troisièmement que tout ça se passant
à deux mois du départ de la transat de
le favori officielle et est herlin sur
le vendredi 13 bateaux géants mais pour
moi le vrai favori parce qu'un bateau
formidablement au point avec un marin
tout à fait
acoquiné faisant corps avec son bateau
il n'y avait pas de doute le couple
favori c'était cola et benfica
et pourtant seul un bateau attire tous
les regards au départ de l'oscar 72
celui de jean-yves terlain vendredi 13
long de 33 m et données généralement
vainqueur cola fait figure d'épouvantail
dans le milieu très fermé des coureurs
au large son ambition surprend parfois
même son assurance irrite que là m'a
étonné parce que il avait une capacité
au fond d'étudiants 1 et d'étudiants
sérieux une capacité à apprendre assez
exceptionnel doublé d'un culot monstre
c'est peut-être qu'on lui a reproché le
plus d'ailleurs ensuite cette espèce de
prétention affichée qui faisaient que ça
paraissait par moments
un peu et on tait en réalité il était
très timide et sa cache à une ambition
forcené il avait l'envié de démontrer
que celui qu'on appelait le petit
cuisinier là pouvait être un grand marin
dès le départ colas est placé en
vainqueurs potentiels sur l'eau les
événements vont lui donner raison
cette transat 72 se joue ici au moment
de la rencontre historique entre pendik
4 et vendredi 13
une image de légende celle des deux
prétendants à la victoire
au coude à coude en plein milieu de
l'atlantique rendent compte que j'avais
fait jusque-là jeu égal avec mon nom mon
adversaire direct dans les conditions
qui étaient les siennes
c'était extraordinaire mais je lui
relais sur place j'étais tellement
excité je leur je me suis mis aussitôt
au labeur et puis était chez jusqu'à ce
que j'ai rattrapé et puis quand je suis
arrivé à sa hauteur
ce que j'ai trouvé à dire c'était s'est
résumée en un geste je vais faire un
signe de la main puis il m'a regardé un
bon moment et puis il arpente est ce le
pont de son bateau jusqu'à l'avant et là
il s'est assis à l'avant dans son balcon
il regardait ses voiles à regarder son
réglage et puis je suis arrivé
exactement
sa hauteur je peux passer là il m'a fait
un grand saut et j'ai rien grasset et
puis c'est difficile à résumer à noter
qu'à tromper tabarly un autre français
gagnent aux stars vendredi 13 passe la
ligne quelques heures après que la chose
de louche son sponsor reste beau joueur
et résume le sentiment général
comme je sais que vendredi 13 d'un
bateau qui marche très fort je peux vous
dire que la marche est encore préfèrent
donc la performance de halak aulas entre
dans la légende
son exploit au niveau de la notoriété
médiatique il va en jouer
cet infatigable meneur de projet devient
un héros il prépare déjà une nouvelle
aventure le 8 septembre 73
il quitte saint malo pour un tour du
monde en solitaire sur son trimaran
rebaptisé manureva collab battre le
record de schiste heures est allé se
frotter au cap horn
le projet coûte cher il sera donc
financé on découvre le sponsoring cacher
c'est une révolution
c'est le premier qui avait compris qu'il
fallait servir du public comme une
caisse de résonance et que le public
appréciait justement d'être informés
d'être tenu au courant des usages de la
radio doudou les photos faites en mer
d'autre part il avait compris également
que des industriels pouvaient les
financer ces bateaux et que c'était pas
on te traite hausse très important car à
l'époque ça ne se faisait pas et puis le
troisième élément dans lequel je crois
il avait été également un précurseur
c'est que il avait compris que les
médias pouvaient lui servir pour
justement toucher à la fois les
spectateurs mais également les
industrielles dont il avait compris
qu'il fallait avoir ces trois pouces et
trois éléments les mêlées ensemble et
comme ça on a été efficace il a tout ce
qui a été fait après depuis a été
directement inspiré de ce qu'avait
trouvé cola
se calant cola compris c'est qu'il
devrait intéresser le plus large public
à ses aventures il devient donc le
premier journaliste réalisateur coureurs
d'océans
il met en scène ses exploits envoie des
chroniques radio écrit des livres à
terre ses films servent de support à des
conférences où il décrit longuement sa
passion car c'est le premier marin qui
parle et relate ses exploits le premier
à s'appuyer sur les médias pour faire
vivre son rêve
c'est le premier qui après avoir obtenu
par sa victoire le droit à la parole et
à la notoriété à exploiter cette
notoriété mais c'est aussi le premier
qui alors que il avait acheté son bateau
sans aucune aide
un ensemble étant complètement a compris
que ça pouvait devenir son instrument de
travail que ça devait même devenir son
instrument de travail d'assister à une
conférence de colin bell qui parlait il
parlait d'une mer que moi je connaissais
pas mais peu importe non c'est pas
critique dit que je connaissais pas
parce que je n'aurais jamais pu raconter
ce qu'ils racontent m et transmettait
transmettait son émotion c'est ses joies
et ses difficultés il faisait de façon
bien c'est les gens seront pas le public
et les gens qui viennent dans une salle
et qu'ils écoutent quelqu'un qui parle
si les pro et anti qui peut les faire
jeter un oeil à vous dire sympa s'être
la salle elle écoutait mais d'attendre
entendu un autre volet c'était silence
total et roost est génial
[Applaudissements]
on va passer le cap horn cette masse
rocheuse qui pénètre virilement dans
l'océan où toute la dentelle des sommets
des des anfractuosités traduit bien là
la dureté que c'est merlin
où il ya un espèce de fondus de glauque
enchaîné entre le ciel et la mer
[Applaudissements]
et l'on passe on s'en rend qu'il a vu le
miracle d'y arriver par beau temps quand
on pense qu'au siècle dernier les vieux
de la voile sont passés dans le sud du
cap horn loin repoussé par les tempêtes
ou 20 avaient été masquées par les
trains et on passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cent soixante neuf jours plus tard
manureva se présente face aux remparts
de saint malo cola et cap hornier des
milliers de gens sont venus de lui dire
il se rend quelques jours après à
greenwich en pèlerinage pour admirer le
cat is arq un clippeur du siècle dernier
habitué du cap horn
colas est fasciné par cette époque de la
marine à voile
il rêve d'un bateau long et racé comme
un flipper mes équipes et d'appareillage
ultramoderne un architecte marseille et
michel bigouin lui propose les plans
d'un quatre mâts long de 72 m la coque
et mises en chantier à toulon pendant
que démarrent les premiers essais en
soufflerie à la colla relève un énorme
défi dans un scepticisme général
et au moment où le sort va le frapper
durement week-end de pentecôte tragique
à la trinité le cordage d'une entre lui
la bourle pied droit coupe en chair et
os une erreur d'inattention fatale
il donnait les ordres il était froid ils
avaient vraiment la paire du papa du
63ème minute année je reviens pas moi je
suis vraiment surpris de ce courage
c'est incroyable
les chirurgiens de l'hôpital de nantes
font un miracle alain colas en fera un
autre celui de diriger seul depuis sa
chambre tout la construction du
quatre-mâts et en subissant 22
opérations
[Musique]
fatigué le visage rond du aiguë par la
douleur il assiste sur des béquilles au
lancement spectaculaire de la coque de
son bateau à toulon le procédé est
original puisque le 80 est lancé à
l'envers avant de se retourner d'un coup
sec dans un grand bruit d'eau fouetter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la transat anglaise démarre quelques
semaines plus tard à toulon une armée de
bénévoles se lève et improvise un
chantier dans une grande fièvre
le maxi bateau devient un outil
technologique inouïe dont le premier
devis se monte à plus de 5 millions de
francs il sera quasiment tripler la qui
contient de l'uranium inertes des
caméras sont installées au pied des mâts
aux 2 34 mètres et qui porteront mille
mètres carrés de toile des ordinateurs
prennent place dans la timonerie et
pourtant alain colas se défend d'avoir
conçu un bateau presse bouton ce qui
nous a d'abord séduit c'est le progrès
technologique de ça représentait ce qui
nous a séduit aussi c'est la méfiance de
tous les autres contre son génie et ça
c'était enthousiasmant d' de sentir de
savoir qu'il avait raison tout seul
contre tous les autres alors non et en
plus il faut bien le dire
comme presque toujours avec un an il
avait une façon de renvoyer l'ascenseur
qui était tellement extraordinaire que
vous croyez au début que vous l'aidiez
est en fait c'est lui qui nous étaient
au départ de la transat 76 club
méditerranée créé l'événement et la gêne
chez les organisateurs anglais
la presse britannique suggère déjà un
règlement qui limiterait la taille des
bateaux
alain colas vit mal ces tracasseries il
dérape dans ses déclarations
la lutte sera cher pour la seconde place
dit il alors que beaucoup se demandent
comment cet homme presque un fiom pour
amener seul ce bateau gigantesque cinq
tempêtes successives qui la flotte à
newport tabarly surgit de la brume et
souffle la victoire à colas qui passe la
ligne 7 heures plus tard après avoir
fait escale à terre-neuve
alain colas n'est pas un perdant ses
déclarations s'en ressent
on a tellement dit que je récupérerai
jamais ma jambe on a tellement dit que
c'était à bateaux qui ne marcherait pas
c'était un bateau que je ne pourrais pas
mener et je le mener si bien je faisais
marché si fort j'ai eu trop à coeur de 2
2 pouces et la démonstration a terminé
second set être battu alain colas
grimace n'ai pas de douleur mais de
dépit désormais il a une revanche à
prendre sur manureva qu'il a marqué dans
sa chair sur le monde des coureurs qui
vit mal certaines déclarations sur
tabarly qu'il provoque en duel dans la
prochaine transat alors contre l'avis de
ses proches
il est au départ de la première route du
rhum en 78 manureva et retapé à la hâte
mais c'est désormais un vieux bateau
d'emblée alain colas se porte en tête de
course
une fois encore il cravache sa monture
n'hésite pas envoyer toute la toile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
colas la marine nationale a décidé de
stopper les recherches aériennes depuis
le 24 novembre plus d'un mois donc de
breguet atlantique l'un basé à pointe à
pitre l'autre aux açores ratisser chaque
jour l'océan pour tenter de repérer le
bateau d'alain colas je lui avais un peu
parler de ceux de sa disparition jeudi à
l'aise tu vas partir tu vas sur moi pour
renier parce que j'ai vraiment des
naissances a feeling très très très très
intérieure et donc quand il a disparu je
me suis dit voilà donc mon intérêt avéré
gens c'est terrible de perdre nos faux
d'un morceau de vous-même qui sera
tournée toujours un petit toujours une
petite idée de dire est ce que je verrai
on n'a rien trouvé de son atout on
absolument rien retrouvé une année on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de concerts
impossible
pas une bouée pas un bout de flotteurs
ce manque d' indice va alimenter de bien
étrange rumeur certains imaginent un
coup médiatique ou colle à cacher sur
une île déserte ces insinuations révolte
ses proches moi je me disais pendant que
mon frère est en train d'advenir qu'il a
peut-être plus d'eau que rien à bouffer
chez des espèces de [ __ ] qui raconte
ce genre d'histoire alors qu'alain
c'était là c'était la vie même
je trouvais c'était pas la peine de
s'inquiéter puis après je dis bah il a
monté une combine
et puis après après j'ai regretté qu'il
n'ait pas monter unis ce qu'on l'a pas
retrouvée je suis passé par différentes
phases
après j'aurai et après j'aurais vraiment
bien aimé qu'on retrouve chez les colas
on ne baisse pas les bras
plusieurs mois après la disparition
d'alain le moindre indice et exploiter
décortiquer les radiesthésistes les
voyantes semaine de la partie de sombres
crétins joue sur la douleur d'une
famille un message contenu dans une
bouteille retrouvée sur une plage info
imitant la signature la france fantasme
sur sa disparition pendant que ses
proches se morfondent avant de se rendre
à l'évidence manureva a coulé à pic
une dernière photo du trimaran montre qu
alain porter toutes ces voiles en pleine
tempête
alors qu olivier de kersauson filmé dans
la même zone est pratiquement à sec de
toiles manureva fatigué par ses efforts
sera disloquée à la cola a brisé le rêve
[Musique]
tout ça c'est quand même fait pour ce
pour se marrer pour que ça soit beau
parce que c'est un sport qui dit vin
parce que les bateaux font énormément de
progrès parce que on fait ça parce que
c'est des vies qu'on aime vraiment et
une fille qu'on une fille qu'on aime
vraiment elle se marie pas vraiment avec
l'idée de la mort puisque on veut que
toujours que ce qu'on aime soit
éternelle donc le regard qui est porté
sur les bateaux dans les les gens de mer
et où c'est quand même toujours un
regard où il ya tout le temps il est il
est éternel il faut qu'il soit éternelle
puis c'est tellement beau c'est comme
l'amour faut pas que ça s'arrête
c'était un moment fantastique c'était un
moment exaltant c'était une c'était une
vie de ces c'est vraiment été un moment
merveilleux mais la seule chose malgré
la disparition d'alain allaire a disparu
mais s'il me disait si je reviens alors
lorsque je les quitte est ce ce jour
dans les cinq minutes avant le coup de
deux coups de canon au départ c'était le
dernier à quitter le bord et si et si ce
mot cet instant là était à revivre et
qu'il me dise à cet instant jef tu
restes avec moi je resterai parce que
peut-être qu'à deux on s'en sortirait
[Musique]
le temps n'efface pas tout à clamecy les
souvenirs du fils prodige sont encore à
vif et certaines nuits le sommeil bien
difficile à trouver pour tous ceux qui
l'ont aimé alain colas n'est pas tout à
fait mort puisqu'il n'est que disparu la
peine ne peut faire oublier qu'il était
un grand marin un précurseur un homme de
projets innovateurs génial dans le monde
très fermé des coureurs d'océans la
course au large a été touché par le
syndrome cola ses photos ses bibelots
curieusement conserver ses trophées
rappelle à l'évidence l'homme d'action
bourré d'une énergie vitale
encore récemment ramené en surface par
l'actualité
club méditerranée racheté par bernard
tapie réaménagé rebaptisé phocéa a battu
le record de l'atlantique de charlie
barr une manière de démontrer qu alain
colas avait eu raison douze ans plus tôt
en construisant son maxi bateau même ses
plus farouches détracteurs l'admettent
colas était un visionnaire aspirer il
lègue une fabuleuse odyssée à ses trois
enfants ava ient mythique la fille d'un
tour du monde à ses jumeaux tereva et
aurait alors oui femina c'est bien et
puis samedi à pourquoi saviez très bien
très bien même pas voler pièces volées
c'est maintenant qu'il faut regarder
c'est plutôt apporté voulez regarder
évoluer les bateaux
ces enfants sont là et j'ai vraiment des
enfants qui vivent au travers de
souvenirs de leur père et je cultive un
souvenir c'est normal pour leur bien
être personnel et pour leur propre
personnalité d'un coup leur propre
avenir afin qu'ils soient pas des
enfants ne sachant pas qui ils sont et
d'où ils viennent à la cola ne reste pas
un exemple pour ses seuls enfants
son nom n'a jamais complètement disparu
des consciences les effets de son
passage sur mer se font encore sentir
dix ans après ils représentent toujours
la passion d'un marin qui a su vivre ses
rêves jusqu'au bout c'est la marque de
l'authenticité
le propre d'un grand bonhomme c'est de
ne jamais vous abandonner complètement
[Musique]
souvent moi je les plombs se réalise
dans la tête s'il arrivait manon durant
l'interview ça me fait vraiment mal
ça me ferait plaisir conscience que tout
le côté obscène de 2
de la mort de la vie qui se termine mal
qui est fait à la caméra un coup il ya
un côté souvent moi j'ai envie de ces
films là je me projette dans la tête
c'est que c'est tout ça ça ne sera que
des mots des cauchemars un camp fait bon
bah on a eu peur on a pleuré mais c'est
pas grave
en fait c'est pas le cas mais pas
toujours
[Musique]